[Music]
whoa right it has been another busy
month in the world of eSports so it's
time for us to bring you guys up to
speed on the biggest bits of news in
just 60 seconds so three two one
takeaway oh okay
fair enough yeah face it announced the
launch of the quake Pro League no
warning their virtual team liquid reveal
Avengers eSports jerseys after
partnering with mouths vici gaming
secured victory at the epicenter dota 2
major in Russia
at Team Liquid that lifts the csgo
trophy the ESL one cologne
and then another blast series I mean
that's not that do you think looks
pretty impressive Shanghai dragons of 0
and 4 2 thames win phase 3 playoffs of
the overwatch team an eva 2019 reveal
incredible entrant numbers for the
outcome in event phase plan take the top
prize at punky europe bleep face
blizzard reveal ambition homestand plans
for 2020 absolutely amazing stuff there
and only that we'll have more live
coverage on the homestand events later
on in the show in one of our features so
stay tuned for that now Rachel what of
those events caught your eye at this
month well it's gonna ask me Shanghai
dragons isn't it season one terrible
record not impressive season two I mean
just the comeback of all comebacks their
winning stage three so you know take a
bow Shanghai dragon it's gotta be there
what would you say Evo so many people
getting involved such a huge tournament
and to see those numbers every year is
getting bigger and bigger absolutely
made in for the earth the FT this guy
can talk all afternoon but like time fee
now it's got the little control center
up there there he goes he's off and he's
gone so while mark is up there getting
ready in that control center I thought
we could take a look at one of the
biggest crazes that has been super
sweeping the eSports scene this month so
many of our eSports favorites have been
having fun by applying you know it's
gonna be that old filter to their photos
basically last week 150 a million of you
have taken part in this it's all
artificial intelligence of course I have
a look our favorite selections right
here yes
Alex and Machine Richardson doesn't look
too bad
League of Legends pros they're all nine
of them look at those
these are terrible at me Richard Lewis
wowsers you should use secret
Duncan Thorin shields that the historian
of eSports look at him Oh oh yeah that
is mark
onset patcher sorry that's just why I
look like to be honest that's kind of
where we at but if you're gonna throw
some shade my way Rachel you used to get
on that you know what's about to happen
but yeah let's have a look at Rachel
then do I really have to say anything ah
do I really have to I didn't want Russia
to have my information I think you
didn't why to be honest I do you think
you know me only actually like annoyed
that you've just felt that but I look
too bad as a as an old lady I think you
lip-read been using moisturizing cream
since I was 12 years old it clearly
doesn't work does it I think I think you
look pretty good but for now it is time
to hit the control center welcome along
ladies and gentleman it's time to
basically wrap up the social media and
everything eSports related that's on the
Internet at the moment and we're gonna
kick things off with someone that we had
actually here last week and that is of
course scope from Team method we had him
on the show talking about the race for
world first that is currently underway
and this is how the guys are getting on
you can see they're on their last boss
at the moment seven out of eight things
done they're really getting into it so I
mean this is how the guys are getting on
right now
[Music]
any evidence
[Applause]
maintains right now 4 million 3 million
the sky and their favorite chair
[Music]
absolutely amazing stuff from the boys
their schoen method doing a great job
and best of luck going forward to trying
to win that race excuse me for
world-first now next up all support in
sides in the world right they have their
bogey teams they have the team that they
struggle against and it's no different
for counter logic gaming you can see it
here the team that they have a problem
against is obviously TSM it has been
1176 days which is a number that I just
about managed to get out of my mouth to
be honest with you and they haven't
managed to pick up a win over them but
this streak has been ended you can see
it here for this streak the streak is
dead I repeat the streak is dead now to
put that into perspective that
incredible amount of time here's a list
of things that you could do in the time
it's taken to lift the curse CLG
defeated TSM ending of 1176 a losing
streak in that time you could have all
of those things sound incredibly
exhausting and I think it just sums up
exactly how long that has taken but
congratulations
- of course CLG now let's talk about one
team in particular who's doing very well
at the moment that's Team Liquid
obviously they've recently partnered up
with Marvell we heard about it in our
eSports 60 roundup and it seems like
that the liquid players are kind of
taking this on their shoulders a little
bit they've had a little bit of fun with
it and you can see it here superheroes
in training Team Liquid looking
absolutely phenomenal at the moment to
be honest I think if any villain saw
those guys coming over the horizon then
there'd be a little bit skeptical about
continuing with their acts of nastiness
but anyway the next thing we're going to
talk about is of course dota now we have
our 18 teams that are set to do battle
now at the international and there is an
absolutely astronomical prize port and
that gets me excited because it gets my
favorite thing to do it is press this
button here which works beautifully it
is time for the compendium watch which
is of course means we are gonna have a
look at how the prize pool is standing
at the moment we could see it loading up
in the background here I can tell you
actually as we see here it comes
2019 thirty million dollars we are at
the moment
and that means as we can see from this
tweet from Wickham here that it is now
surpassing 30 million dollars which
means it's the largest prize pool for
any single tournament in the history of
eSports that is absolutely insane coming
in from those guys congratulations to
all of the DOTA community for their
contributions and that's going to be one
hell of event the International this
year now next up over by HP update and
we have some incredibly exciting news
for you guys about the Nvidia and omen
vs. frames win games event coming your
way in just a few days now this is gonna
be an incredible event it can be very
exciting so check it out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
absolutely amazing stuff and just to
give you a little bit more information
on exactly what's going on there six
teams of streamers representing their
reasons will be fighting out on both
APEC legends and for tonight absolutely
incredible stuff it's going to be a
fantastic watch for more details if you
want to find out a little bit more about
it head over to Nvidia calm everything
that you need to know is there now
that's everything from around the world
of social media and eSports let's have a
look now what's coming up today here's
what's in store for tonight's show we
take a look at a legendary smite play in
the break down as the esports awards
approaches we get our predictions
[Music]
suntouch joins us in the studio
and finally we show you what to look out
for in the month ahead the show is
absolutely sucks so don't go anywhere
and definitely make sure you keep tuned
for that rocket League challenge where
I'll be going head-to-head against mark
and if you've been watching the series
you kind of know what's gonna happen and
it'll see you do stay tuned for that you
could win some amazing prizes if you
correctly predict that winner you're not
gonna give any details on how you can
enter and what you get your hands on our
on the screen right now so basically
what are you waiting for go go go go go
right this is pretty much my favorite
part of the show is time to introduce
our wonderful guest today first up we
have suntouch how are you I bet you're
pretty pleased to be in here because
it's like 38 degrees outside pretty hot
Bahamas it is again so for this so far
the Stoker's emanating heat in some
respect we look good that is a hot count
also mainly because of Adam's shirt
thank you that's it emanate a lot no
jungle for next time I have my in animal
savage in animal over here on some touch
well we know a little bit a little look
in more detail about exactly what you
get big
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
please when you put your like your head
in your hands obviously something [ __ ]
every wrong has well basically what's
happened there so tries for a grenade
out of a window
obvious the buggy a scheme to exist say
excuses that buggiest game yes obviously
tactics puppy then they let them slide
anymore okay sorry but thanks so much
for coming like you know what would be
up to you recently tell us what you've
been doing
yeah I've been streaming the new game
team fight tactics and trying to become
rank one in it that's my goal in life
right now okay it started basically the
beginning like the smite eSports scene
and kind of how he got involved in that
firstly yes I was playing counter-strike
at a time which is a FPS and I was
dabbling in dota 2 heroes of newerth and
stuff and I was like my friends like you
should try out smite it's kind of like
those two games me and I was like I'm
not gonna try that and I was like
they're like it's free oh sorry out down
later there and I just loved it and it
was great and actually my friends
refused to play and Meeks I was so bad
they actually told me the I retired yeah
yeah well I said I would say oh they
don't they were the one playing me so I
she stopped playing and then after about
like five or six months like that I came
back into it I practice and I ended up
becoming a pro player tell us a little
bit about the eSports scene because
smite kind of was one of those smaller
communities as you say a free-to-play
game when it was first released but
really has kind of found its own sort of
burgeoning eSports scene and really
become something little bit special
yeah hi-rez studios makers of smite have
really just put an emphasis on how much
they want to like make their eSports
seem great healthy good for the players
and that's the crucial thing I think is
like player kind of retention and like
making sure everyone's got like a safe
career right that people who love ya
love their and they ended up actually
building a studio in Alpharetta Georgia
and they flew out all of the players to
live there so they've got their paper
houses they've got the studio and the
whole thing
every single week and they're getting
salary this is great and you know what's
happened now yeah
sounds pretty good how many minutes
smart team five hey the Fab five we can
swap out a map I've not really played
smite ever I go cool if I want to go get
to get to a level where I can compete
professionally okay how many hours
laughs to invest in that game okay I've
seen you I'm rocket League and I know
your background someone look at maybe
like a million hours a million hours
maybe a million hours give up a hundred
how many years is that someone could
work a lot of Tour de France's I'll
train you you'll train me 100 dollars an
hour you can't sell your service I'm
here right anyway let's move on no team
fight tactics something you kind of
recently got involved with kind of
change direction a little bit haven't
you yeah I mean I just wanted to try a
game that was most rity jerkle where I
could use my brain it was less about
like your reflexes and more about
mathematical probability and stuff which
I really enjoy and the game itself is
just great if you haven't played it you
should try it out it's it was so free so
why not and you just basically buy
champions you place it onto a board and
they fight someone else's champion today
forward so every single game is
different that's the kind of exciting
part about it I know I'll have a little
stalk before came on the show and you
were tweeting jari who we had on the
show last night yeah yeah
you've been teaching her how she been
getting on yeah well Joey I've been
teaching her she may be a lost cause you
might be a lost cause but she's got a
good heart
she's out there trying he's watching
this and crying right now you know she
might be crazy yeah she's got a good
what she can do is you can see the tears
and sell them I can't get a go easy
let's talk about a potential eSports
team because obviously this has been
kind of Auto chess has been the buzz
words for you know around a month now
yeah with the introduction of the genre
to to eSports and competitive gaming I
mean what do you think for an eSports
scene 14 fire tactics you see something
happening here I think it can be pretty
big because you've got all these
companies huge companies ready but Valve
epic
and riot now making their own also chess
games so they're gonna be wanting to
compete for eSports titles so you can
produce the best one and I think there's
gonna be a pretty healthy school scene
I'm looking forward to it again Boise
you got any time at the moment you could
kind of get involved in like a new
project
I'm sadly lacking in an 18-point board
gives you plenty of time spare time I'm
sure you play one game and then you're
you're sucked away forever be careful
it's very addictive I've lost I've lost
some friends
look it did look pretty addictive yeah
yeah yeah you've mostly been playing and
watching stage yeah gotta get my Smurfs
the diamond talking a little bit about
streaming because obviously you are a
part of the omen squad you know and
you've had some fantastic opportunities
presented to you tell us a little bit
about that
it's been great like since I started
streaming about a really nice community
and smite and they supported me
streaming itself is just a it's like an
it's a challenge because you've if you
do want to switch game you've got to try
and keep your audience to be interested
because you know smite and teamfight
tactics or it's my in pub gee are such
different games you're the people that
enjoy watching smite might know what
enjoy watching play the other games so
it's a bit of a challenge but it's very
fun and you get opportunities to play
all over the world say which isn't great
I love hearing your story thank you very
much son tuck if you have two more
guests to speak to a little bit but this
have a look at what else is coming up on
tonight's show here's what's in store
for tonight's show our guests alien
skills are put to the test in the
headshot challenge
as the eSports Awards approaches we give
our predictions we take a look at a
legendary slight play in the Brendon and
we head to Atlanta to experience our
host and weekend ok time to pick two of
our guests against each other now all
this exciting I see you today I grabbed
mr. Adam Savage and Bravo and asked them
to go toe-to-toe in our head shot Jones
let's see how that went down
right this is the csgo head shot
challenge with Adam Savage right so if
you haven't watched before you need to
know some rules so six seconds on the
clock okay to get as many head shots as
possible of course the timer starts when
you first headshot okay doesn't it I
would say easy but it sounds
straightforward when it's about to hit a
whole lot more difficult because I'm
really asking you some really difficult
questions so it's not even as easy just
answering questions because you have to
answer the question before last right
yeah I'm with you so you're gonna ask me
a question and I have to answer the
previous question in that questions
answer well I think that's how it goes
blowing that break good answer these
questions so let's hope you're better
answering them okay are you ready I am
ready yeah okay so okay on your account
guys right which is the river in Egypt
okay what do with csgo released the Nile
tallest mountain in the world the
question was I forgot I forgot what is
the current prize pool for the
International was it a Sahara how many
legs does a bottle I have not gonna help
you okay 25 million what is the largest
ocean in the world ten five seconds who
wrote A Song of Ice and Fire
I wasn't this is question I think was it
you know yeah too bad really
Rachel pretty difficult but you are
against someone you're against Bravo how
you feeling about that oh well that's
easy then I've smashed it I don't see
how he gets on thank you Bravo is in the
hot seat okay you ready
I think I'm ready okay weigh the river
in Egypt
what year was csgo released niall
tallest mountain in the world
2007 16 what game came up a rocket
League okay before goldeneye for n64
biggest desert in the world
Goldeneye friend 64 to answer the last
one boy the current price both the
International ahh
the Sahara how many legs does a
butterfly have over 30 million dollars
what is the largest ocean in the world
live 8 what is the best-selling PC game
of time Pacific was the fifth planet in
the universe
World of Warcraft what game led to mods
pub G and Daisy mercury done stop the
clock
stop everything lee moses you have
finished yeah all right I'm not gonna
say Gyu won or not you have to wait
because I'm about to reveal the answers
right yeah I mean I thought about what
even holy Moses Bravo but anyway let's
reveal exactly what went down there drum
roll died were right are you on that no
you didn't get one two or three maggot
clothes didn't get close to that move on
October 26 27 26 okay happy with that
not as worried as he looked for you
please thanks for three people that
shared their genuinely that's super
tough isn't it yeah we knew asking
questions really threw me off but that's
the real reason why otherwise I would
have absolutely killed it yeah you
couldn't really remember after them
mountain Everest the Nile yes so really
easy question Ivana guys are you happier
there I think
Bravo looks slightly stressed on the
couch still I feel pretty good he didn't
beat mark I had to just beat Adam well I
mean for bride I didn't he probably
cheated it's mark I can carry on with
his banner all day but I'm not going to
anyway Bravo congratulations what about
it Adam sorry let's move on let's just
move on to what happens next so the
breakdown we love a bit of breakdown so
earlier on the show we took a deal
I've into the world of smite that mark
and Sun touch filmed yeah little bit
earlier have a look at this welcome
ladies and gentlemen to my favorite part
of the show it's where we get someone
wonderful this week it's of course
suntouch to help you guys out at home
and also break down as we like to say
some pretty high-level gameplay now you
are known as mr. smight that's what
going to call you right now
ex-professional you know all about the
game burbs mate for some people who
don't tell us a little bit about smite
why smite okay so smites the third
person MOBA most people know League of
Legends or dota very similar to that but
kind of like an FPS spin on it so you're
coming over the top of your character
and you're aiming your skill shots with
your mouse rather than like clicking to
move and stuff see move of WASD and
myself I was a former csgo player our CS
1.6 as well and I just love it it's so
similar it's like FPS meets League I
love it now one thing that I absolutely
love is the three words here
free-to-play which is you know if you're
a home and you're thinking I've got
nothing to play how do I get into a new
game free to play is always a fantastic
thing to get involve something's free
just download I give it a go like don't
be cynical and be like oh just like if
it looks good then you think you'll have
fun download it give it a shot what have
you've literally got nothing to lose now
something that might be a little bit
more confusing for people are looking
what exactly we talked about with
pantheon of gods okay so it's just all
their characters and smite are based
around gods so if you're in so kind of
mythology and stuff like that so it's
kind of nice to say well let's talk
about some pro gameplay let's talk about
that high-level stuff that we love to
delve into and this one's not just a
fantastic play it's it's very close to
your heart it's a real celebration of a
good friend of yours ally to sadly isn't
with us anymore but this played the
pentakill is something you don't see
very often and certainly is a fantastic
way to celebrate his gaming yeah we can
just roll it so you'll see a light here
it's just rolling into like danger takes
down one kill takes down the second kill
great stone coming out they're setting
them up for the fur kill and normally
teams are looking to end now because
they've got those free kills but you
will see allied you're meant to kill
this objective allied was started by the
way this is 100% mayor's like he's like
like he needs four fencer and there's
then even I think one Penta kill
throughout the whole of smite world
championship so this would be like the
second one takes to the sky
hits the snipes and you're gonna see
like a lovely role here into the finish
and the pentakill goes crazy in the
bottom I love slowly men so hands off
the keyboard and they were the underdogs
and they once say amazing stuff and
obviously we like to wrap these things
up here at the break down with you know
how to get a little bit better for some
of the people who are watching at home
you might be playing smite talk about a
like because he wasn't maybe the top
level skill player but he brought more
than that to the game and maybe some
things that people could take home at
home yes I was kind of this guy who was
known as a good player but not the top
creme de la creme of players so when he
was trying to break onto these teams
they weren't like trying him out and
stuff so what he decided to do was build
his own team and you'll see him now he's
like he's the ingame leader of that team
he put that together so instead of like
being down that he wasn't getting picked
up he said no I am good enough I'm gonna
build my own team improve it and he did
I mean that mentality is everything
really is that you know if you have that
mentality to get better to grind and you
know improve your own game you go so far
yeah just focus on your own plays keep
grinding and just you know be motivated
fantastic stuff well thank you so much
of course for helping us out on the
breakdown before now that's not all
we've got a lot more let's have a look
at what's coming up here's what's coming
up on tonight's shot we head to Atlanta
to experience a homestead weekend
Adam Savage joins us on the sofa
as the eSports Awards approaches we get
our predictions incredible stuff they're
so much more to come on the show what
you're looking forward to I don't know
this is absolutely much a book about it
too much but we got to start somewhere
and we're gonna start with the
second-ever homestand game in the
overwatch league happening just a few
weeks ago it was Atlanta rain who
welcomed all of the teams over to stay
now we wondered if the pressured would
make or break them so we hit the road
and we found out let's check it out
[Music]
[Music]
isn't the first time this out Lana crowd
will get the cheer on their squad in
person
[Music]
for these other seven teams
[Music]
when we talk about the context of home
and away games and you overwatch League
it's something that when it was first
discussed people that did think it would
actually happen and now here we are in
overwatch event happening in the rains
hometown I got into eSports when I was
14 back in like 1998 to go from there to
here now like a packed arena full of
thousands of fans it's always been kind
of my dream almost every other person
here has an Atlanta Rangers you know
where else do you see this real
traditional sports right so this is like
unbelievable like we're just really
starting a new wave being here with all
the fans and seeing everything here it's
insane it's a deeper feeling I wasn't
really into eSports until elana got a
team and then I started watching and I'm
like got really hyped and now I'm like
obsessed with it having a team that you
relate to because they're from your city
makes me feel that I have something to
cheer for outside of just the players or
the organization it's just unbelievable
love and the fans are the best
the hometown energy is always a good
thing the players feed off of it
whatever anxiety they had it's going to
melt away the moment they hear the fans
cheering
[Applause]
to the stage your whole team it's
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it was like unbelievably important to
deliver you know I was not leaving that
stage with a loss that's for sure they
all came here to watch us win that's
what we're here for that we did it I'm
so happy this is honestly one of the
coolest things I've ever done and it's
just really awesome to see a bunch of
like-minded people together and just
getting hyped about a video game an
humans were like communal and tribal in
a way so when we have something like a
banner we can get behind it makes it
that much easier I caught some eclairs
earlier and I was like I don't even care
if you're the best team because you're
my team and you have so much charisma
that's all I care about I want something
root for and they give me that every
time that way especially today the
experience that happened here today is
something that needs to happen more in
eSports we're just at the start you know
this this event is bigger than eSports
are bigger than just overwatch
today every eSports player has to go
through something like this because this
is wonderful it's such a fun experience
[Music]
I'm definitely in Atlanta rain convert
I'm a fan massive fan looked awesome
didn't it yeah I mean the fact that they
get in the hometown behind them I think
is an absolutely you know phenomenal
thing it really gives you know local
fans something to get their teeth into
not only that the overwatch league has
announced a load of Homestead games for
every single team that's involved so a
lot more of that to come exciting times
the overwatch League right time for our
second guests on the couch you see Adam
Savage I mean we know a lot about your
dress style you're great I'm not sure
we're over here back it is if you don't
know much more than have a look at mr.
savage here on screen right now
[Applause]
kick the whole thing aims again would
you please give it up
are you guys ready cuz I am
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
seems like crowds just absolutely lovely
mate what can I say
what can I say it was in that experience
in itself was absolutely insane I mean
that video yeah and that was yeah I mean
I've just never seen a host turn to a
packed house like that and the place go
nuts oh I just had a baby like not my
parents my wife obviously but we are we
yeah he Rafferty was my son and I
thought I'm in this moment where we had
in Copenhagen where the royal arena
think it's called twelve and a half
thousand fans like CS fans at the blast
Pro Series was absolutely crackers it
was it was it was nuts and I had this
just epiphany this moment I thought I'm
gonna do something special because you
know soften we kind of we're so lucky to
do the shows that we do and kind of be
in these amazing experiences and I think
I got to get something that I know that
I was there in the moment thinking of
him and so I just I thought I'd make a
video thinking you know one day you
asked what I did for a living or what I
do for a living
here's an example isn't that right
Denmark and everyone's where'd you get
so that moment of a sea just walking
become a hosts in front of thousand
people you know what we should you only
like go working out I just paid up all
the right people I mean it was just my
the the whole eSports journey up in on I
guess has been it's been it's been great
it's been so many different things that
I've done over the last I'd say four
years or so since I first got into kind
of a eSports stratosphere we were just
chatting I think it kicked off kind of
back with a halo event about maybe 2016
so I first met you guys was European pro
league finals guys almost just finished
my career there and then I thought I
don't really talk anyway was up exactly
no I remember come away from that show
being really impressed with the work
thanks buddy we've had a chance to do a
few things since well I mean I think the
reason that I've I guess I've continued
to work is I try bring energy a lot of
height to the stuff that I do I think a
lot of times you're gonna go to stage
shows and you want to be entertained of
course you do you know it's not just
about the gameplay you know you watching
the teams you watch it's about the whole
show the experience of being there so
yeah I mean I I mean there was halo we
were chance to get to them before
tonight of course I'm the host of the
blast pro series where and we do you
know all over the world you've done
different events and what is this jump
in on that because you know recently
let's talk about blast Pro Series Moscow
yeah you've got on the horizon that's
next up that's in September the whole
sit we've been so we went to Brazil
early this year to sell power we had
crazy crowds in southern honestly and
MIB are playing as well and it just the
crowd the homes I mean they didn't
perform brilliantly then we all know
that I don't think got one single point
but still it was amazing yeah and the
crowd were absolutely they were just
they were so into we had like people
dancing kind of like you know it was it
was it was great it was a proper party
atmosphere the entire time but we have
Miami Madrid's and that Moscow has come
up next so you know it really does yeah
there's some great there's some great
kind of like booties and stuff we have
as well with them own way HP there as
well so it's I mean the whole the whole
experience has been great very Lucky's
do what I do we think be on stage there
you never take for granted as well yours
kind of thing
I'm in the moment and you know it's
great to entertain so many people and
most other things have done over the
years TV mother stuff II didn't feel
like walking in front of like for coming
from a player point of view as a host
what's it like just being the first one
to walk out there in front of the big
crowds oh it's it's I mean I first
starting out in that in in as a stage
host you kind of it's nerve-wracking you
still it's now you know a big big crowds
but you kind of you kind of there
because you know how to in from the
production standpoint you know how to
you know do this and that and everything
and ultimately it's phenomenal it's the
most amazing experience goosebumps
central because you set the tempo for
the whole event yeah have the reactions
like when you have a crowd that reacts
that way doesn't it it really does sort
of take your breath away and another
thing of course might take your breath
away I'm sorry to cut you off Adam
because we've got to keep this thing
rolling fine is the fact that we're
quickly approaching award season and
there's no different for the eSports
industry as well and the eSports Awards
recently revealed a major facelift for
2019 with some amazing hosts and this
might be the first time you've heard
about these awards and if it is don't
worry we've got you covered so check
this out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so hands up you've been to any Sports
Awards internationally we go there I'm
gonna win an award and then I'll be
there Adam you've hosted it twice before
yeah pretty cool to be honest see that
but what was it like yeah it's being out
there doing it the last four years I've
been the pre and post shows which have
been I mean it's amazing we were
triangular on it it's it's very rare
that in the sports but you space you get
to have black-tie events everyone
dresses up and their finest tuxes and
like you know ball gowns wanna it's a
really great night so it's an amazing
experience you get to hang out with
friends you make meet new friends as
well as kind of reward those people who
are kind of had an amazing job in their
particular field over the course of the
last year so yeah it's really goodness
it is a proper party a proper party as
well everyone nice to let loose and to
have a great time so about you know
potential PC player of the year because
that's something that we have been
talking about we had a little bit of a
thought on some of the players that we
might think would make a very good PC
Player of the Year
[Music]
[Music]
anyone jumping out for you there Adam
that you see is popping off bit of csgo
remain completely yet of course but we
unbiased everyone smart one was great
everyone was really good every was
really good
do we 2k man see he he's the best he's
just like he looks so young
yes oh and I think he's like an
inspiration so like young kids coming up
playing counter-strike and they can see
what he's done like Heather kind of a
rough year with like team swaps and
stuff it's come on it's like Team Liquid
right and just dominated today they're
having an unbelievable run time I think
they've won eight eight of 14 events
they've been out this year so it's crazy
I make happy that list would you kind of
add anybody in there I don't know what's
the crazy for me is every year when we
look at that list and this whole platta
team as well the quality of events the
quality of teams the amount of games
that teams are in if you think about the
category of PC Player of the Year
it's like okay do I pick this league
player do I think the CS player it is
gonna continue to get harder and harder
as the years go on to say all this this
player is definitely better than every
single PC player out there I think it's
a good that list - certainly a good
start but I mean look also if you just
look at the nominees for the eSports was
right every category always has 14
nominees and in almost every category
you're like well 90% of them could
easily take a chance which is pretty
wild see you know how to look at the
players of the year so I look at the
team of the year potentials right now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and there you have hundreds even go back
to back
[Applause]
big names there in that team of the Year
category would you think of those anyone
that well they all stand out really
don't know they do invention teamliquid
already who was he set up to had an
incredible like incredible year so far
hundred thieves as well you know big
year for those guys you know recently
kind of round of funding and staffing of
a repeat the team is really going places
and this is only the beginning really
isn't it I think it makes a great
example as well was how much can happen
in 12 months you know 100 T there
wouldn't been on that list last year
there wouldn't been anywhere near it you
know nature obviously you put together
an organization here that has had a lot
of success and you just wonder you know
where we're gonna be in another 12
months with some of those names that are
there is there gonna be another new name
on there it just it shows how quickly
eSports can change and how quickly
organizations can just rediscover
themselves or did be discovered and be
founded and pick up so much success yeah
I think was kind of cool too is you have
this big race now with these teams that
have that are venture backed it's a
quest if you look at what complexity is
doing in Texas with their facility if
you look at what 100th you've just
announced with their facility we're in a
point in eSports where it's a race to
who can provide the absolute best player
training who can provide the best
facilities and then what does that
translate to and results and that was
not the case even two years ago so it's
kind of a cool race where these teams
that do have these huge deep pockets now
to invest in their teams they have a
chance to just take home trophy after
trophy yeah absolutely where we have a
look at the players and the teams but
let's have a look at the live events and
some of the potentials that we've picked
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
just quick thing there apparently were
predicting the future 2019 the
International has it happened yet it's
2018 just to correct that very quickly
first blast Pro Series
I mean phenomenal events that happening
it's not even year round now it's every
single week and every single week there
is another a huge eSports event that
he's just blowing everyone's minds yeah
if you look at I mean slasher is kind of
the go-to Twitter account of what
eSports events are happening every
weekend and if you've been following
slasher long enough you've seen that
list of these six eSports events are
happening this weekend - every weekend I
don't know 12 13 it seems across all
these titles it's crazy obvious let me
look at a few facts from last year like
Liga legend world's a hundred million
views just shows like so how big these
events are that concurrent peak 44 mil
so just ridiculous numbers being threw
around that and we knew our numbers
prize money is our the International 30
million dollar sales like one single
event and they made a lot cheddar how
things have changed right yeah I mean I
hate going on about like went back in my
day we've become those people already
but 30 million dollars that's great
event just in sand I mean we should say
as well very quickly sorry I love doing
my plugs you see HP have been nominated
in 2018 as one of the commercial
partners of the year and hardware
provided the year so you just gonna say
the production of these tournaments as
well has been so outstanding you just
see a year after year and you're like
how can he top it and just like
introductions like the music the
theatrical performances they're bringing
in it's almost like trying to contest
like the Super Bowl you know yeah yes I
just love that we have a Super Bowl
every weekend we've got so much to talk
about still let's have a quick reminder
of what is coming up in the rest of the
show here's what's still to come
see mark and team Rachel faceoff in the
rocket League challenge we sit down with
Bravo to talk all things eSports and
finally we show you what to look out for
in the month ahead well now it is time
to have a little chat to our third and
final guests over here Bravo we just saw
there is quite a hungry chap on you I
think yeah mark and perhaps Adam too can
attest to the fact that yeah I'm
generally pretty hungry I'm actually
hungry right now
you can definitely smash a rap
reflecting with you eating a cookie it's
true you can eat after we show everybody
exactly what you get up but yeah
this is Bravo beautiful double there too
oh my gosh look at the damage he's doing
here staying alive frost he comes in to
clean up those two kills as well shoots
[Music]
you want hungry overtime no cookies in
there as well
yep I don't know who chose the to
include most of me eating cookies but we
also had a little delve into Twitter
like it with the Sun touch there and his
collaboration to jari you got the stalk
Rachel I do that's what I'm gathering -
yeah we found something which I was kind
of like you know we love a throwback but
I'm kind of holding on so yesteryears
and this olivia munn from tweet and prom
with Olivia Munn obviously they're very
successful actress now but my question
to you there it is lovely picture Oh
everybody Oh
but like do you even know her okay
friends do you have a number disbelief I
was asked to come on this show I was not
told that everything would be like
turned against me the headshot challenge
the first question is how do you feel
about losing tomorrow we that would know
that the reason so whenever people do
see that photo they do compare me to jay
from jay and silent bob is usually in a
really negative way and a lot of
actually when that was posted a lot of
Olivia Munn's fans came out of the
woodwork and they were like what do you
do with this guy there's long hair weird
looking about that no I'm proud to say
that that photo grossly misrepresents
our relationships did she defend you
when her fans are trolling you you I
mean I don't know if we have it but
you've seen her reply
nothing just nothing positivity
if you're curious just head and you can
check out there apply well let's roll
this let's keep the positivity roll in
here okay it's obviously you know you
made your name as a Halo coach back
that's kind of how you got your start in
eSports how you found your way into
things tell us a little bit about that
time yeah I mean that's why she want to
go to prom with me of course she did
apply I'm just being harsh to brother
sorry brother she didn't reply was a
crabber play no yeah I started a
coaching pro Halo during halo 2 so 2000
early 2007 back before I'd say the only
game that had coaching slash manager
roles prior to that in a big way would
be CS with the CGS and a lot of things
that came prior to to halo but I started
coaching pro halo at a time when the
role wasn't really defined yet and I saw
an opportunity to kind of help these pro
teams with strategy tactics and mostly
in-game kind of work and that was in the
day this is before gaming headsets and
you're in huge ballrooms with a thousand
to fifteen hundred guys and girls
competing and the player on the left is
on a tube TV and all the way down three
TVs down the player on the right is on a
TV no one has headsets and I kind of
grew up just screaming and keeping these
teams on the same page I mean yelling
over the rest and all these coaches and
players are just yelling over one
another and it was kind of a cool
opportunity to yet to define the role
and through halo 3 through Halo Reach I
kind of tried to bring I was lucky to be
a part of some championship winning
teams and I tried to just take take the
role really seriously and elevate it any
way I could just give us a little
insight into how if we were you on your
team now how would you like to shout at
us you said I shouting in these players
I mean I want your brother Jimmy
well here's actually I'm becoming it
would be camos up in ten sorry I got
that time wrong anyway let's move on I
wasn't told that I would be roasted the
whole show but I'm having reach because
obviously you know that's moving over to
PC the whole MCC collection moving to PC
very exciting times what your views on
that yeah I think MCC on PC and I think
the whole community feels this way is
just a massive opportunity for the
franchise and in a way that I'm not sure
a lot of people have really realized we
talked about like
if you think about content creators
today streamers they're a huge
percentage I think I would go as far to
say 75 percent plus of your biggest
content creators across YouTube a twitch
mixer etc grew up in some way playing
Halo whether they played the halo 1
campaign whether they played all the
hill and multi players so this game
coming to steam to be available on PC
and to be able to play classic Halo
experiences I think is huge for the game
really curious if we're gonna see PC
eSports if how that's gonna go how is
that gonna take off for Halo and then
what does that mean also of course for
Halo Infinite in holiday 2020 the next
three years for Halo could be absolutely
massive and we could see player bases
that the game that the franchises maybe
hasn't seen in a while or has never seen
so essentially there's just there's a
lot to be excited about and I'm really I
can't wait to see where it goes
I feel like I need to give me some love
now as well and say next up would play
rocket League and you were an awesome
partner so thank you very much for being
excellent say thank you and sorry over
there for just like throwing random boss
anyway right this is the moment we've
all been waiting for
can mark this is the rocket League
challenge alright ladies and gentlemen
welcome along to the rocket League
challenge and this one's got a little
bit more of a serious feel that it
normally does the reason for that is I
am currently kind of 0 and 2 down to
Rachel at the moment but we should
probably introduce Rachel and of course
the person who's gonna be losing
alongside her today is of course a
needed in ski but I have brought in my
special weapon he has zero game time on
rocket League but that doesn't matter
alright guys because this is magic yes
is what's meant to happen it certainly
is let's get into it rocky league Rumble
we've got abilities we've got everything
that all the matters is wait Andy joined
the wrong team let's go boy let's go
let's go
easy I'm in the middle if you need I
mean
Rachel I'm playing about I'm not doing
my look my driver's let's go guys go
losing static is bad right now it's
frozen go I've missed the ball that's
great way to go your people need up 2nd
cushion winner second emissions it to
the difficult to go leave come on sir
that's all you is it really yeah that's
what you and you are doing just get it
down get it down there others I love
this Adam I love this other we've just
been cleared it's okay that is what we
call tire weights and two minutes 20
let's just see this out mark out the way
yes missed it's gonna die deliberately
Oh nearly scored I gotta know I missed
it you got it
so this is great we just see it out one
minute I think I just think you cannot
let this slip so put some ice ball left
[Applause]
that's it gets out gets out so I just
[Applause]
need a knee what's the score
I still watch it I'm sure to watch the
game up there it's nice could be just so
easy why still wouldn't just mark it was
so easy it was so easy to one now first
win of the ball baby let's go I did
yes yes okay
Bravo sorry hands up if deaf and I was
definitely weakest link I would actually
disagree with you there I might yeah I
didn't I didn't perform game playing you
were both that we believe is all I feel
right now I'm not even happy I'm just
imagine if I went all the way through
this series not winning a game yeah next
month I'm back it was deserved that
would have been very very very bad
anyway let's get back on track here it's
been an absolutely crazy schedule that's
gonna be coming up over the next month
and it's almost too much to be honest to
keep a track off good job then but we're
here to help you out here is the month
ahead overwatch returns for its fourth
and final stage of the season a 2-2 to
roll lock could see a big shift in the
meta on the home stretch
[Music]
like a Las Vegas Evo takes place in
early August as fighting game pros from
the various games come together in the
biggest fgc event of the year Call of
Duty scene comes to a close with its
annual World Championship 10100 please
keep up their amazing season find out
the event stop
[Music]
the hostile masters tour continues its
global journey this time visiting solved
for the first event of the new expansion
and finally the biggest prize ball in
eSports is off the grass international
[Music]
so much so much still to come this month
and one thing that we can also say is
that over by HP will be at Gamescom with
some exciting things will be going down
over at their booth so make sure to pop
along if you're at the event and of
course say hi and not only that half the
press ladies and gentlemen only over by
HP are the official PC and a laptop
sponsor for egx 2019 keep up stick the
latest news on all omen at HP news on
our social channels right guys we're
nearly out of time but what has everyone
got coming up Bravo I'm gonna start with
you first let's see after this spending
a few days in Switzerland for the first
time I'm excited and then right back to
Chicago for the next halo post discovery
event next weekend
great mentioned blast by Series Moscow
lots of exciting other projects going on
but there's one on Friday actually I'm
working on a chicken for charity special
effect it's gonna be online follow me on
social details and you'll see everything
it's going with that but I'm yeah
amazing calls and amazing chatter yeah
I'm going to be training to become the
team fight tactics world champion so if
you want you can check me on Twitter or
twitch I'll be teaching the game
alongside my progress and you can learn
a thing or two about the game
that's an incredible stuff and best of
luck with that now speaking of luck it's
time to announce my competition winner
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
this Rachel
public winner and the winner is Roy may
not
I mean this hat is amazing what job look
after having absolute parts of it but
that is unfortunately all we have time
for
so I'm good thank you so much thank you
so so much guys thank you enjoy
incredible stuff thank you so much
audience as well again on August the
28th to bring you even more guests than
even more games and some of these is I
think anyway see you then
cheers I
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you